COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC THE LEGISLATURE AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TRAINING
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING THE
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
SUPPORTERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS.
877-226-8150 TWO THAT.
877-226-8150 TWO AN ACCESS CODE
IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO EIGHT
ONE SEVEN THAT. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE FOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED THE
PUBLIC CON COMMENT. YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. WELL FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTE IT AND YOU'LL BE READY. TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE HEARINGS
ALL HEARING ALTHOUGH BILLS
TODAY ON SCHEDULE AFTER THE
INITIAL WITNESSES OF SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE WILL BAN LIMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT THE FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING THOUSANDS AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE AND HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE. TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING. AND
CONDUCT- HEARING IN AS CLOSE TO
MANNER AS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIME. FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW ONLINE SYSTEM.
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENCE SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES MAY BE HEARD. OF WE
HAVE EIGHT BILLS UP TODAY ON
THE AGENDA- FORTUNATELY A FIVER
ON CONSENT- AB THIRTY FOUR OR
THREE FOUR ONE AB THREE NINE
FOUR AB SIX THREE SIX. IN A V.
SIX FOUR FOUR EIGHT AV. SIX
EIGHT NINE- WE'RE NOT WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WILL START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE- AND THEN AT
SOME POINT WILL COME BACK I SEE
WE HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR HERE
WE HAVE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BIGELOW HERE TO PRESENT. AB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE THE SOMEONE
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL TODAY. TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVEN NINE WHICH WOULD ADD THE
COUNTIES OF DEL NORTE MONO
MADERA AND SAN MATTEO TO
SECTION EIGHT THREE OH POINT
ONE SECTION C. OF THE PENAL
CODE. ALLOWING DEPUTY SHERIFF
TO PERFORM THE DUTIES OF A
PEACE OFFICER AS PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS THESE EMPLOYEES ARE
ALREADY IN UNIFORM AND
OCCASIONALLY HAVE ASSIGNMENTS
THAT TAKE THEM OUTSIDE THE JAIL
SETTING BUT HAVE A MORE LIMITED
ABILITY IN THEIR CAPACITY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR SECTION OF THE LAW
ALLOWS MANY IN FACT MOST OF THE
COUNTIES- IN THE STATE ALREADY
THESE- PRIVILEGES ARE TO BE
ABLE TO DO. SO THIS WOULD BE
JUST ADDING A FEW OF THE- RULE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
THESE SAME LEVELS OF- OF
RESPONSIBILITY. AB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE WOULD REMEDY THE ISSUES BY
ALLOWING CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
TO PERFORM THOSE CORRECTIONS
RELATED TO TASKS- HERE TODAY
WITH ME- IT BY VIRTUE OF
VIRTUAL. ON THE TV SCREENS. OUR
SHARE OF ENGLAND BOB BRAUN FROM
MODEL COUNTY AND RANDY PERRY ON
BEHALF OF PORAC SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
SEE IF THE- WITNESSES IN FACT
IF THERE ARE. OUT THERE IN
CYBER LAND. OKAY WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT WILL PROVIDE EACH US
WITH THIS- THREE MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT- COME TO ME WITH A SELF
SUPPORT. BRADFORD PRESENT
BRADFORD HERE CHOI BOGUE COM
AUGER IN ORDER HERE. ENTER
SKINNER HERE WIENER WE HAVE A
QUORUM. A QUORUM IS PRESENT I
WOULD NOW ASKED FOR H. TWO CAN
WE MAKE A MOTION ON THE FIVE
ITEMS ON CONSENT. THOSE WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SCANNER. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AGAIN
THERE ARE FIVE ITEMS THERE.
CANCEL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AFTER
FIVE I AM FROM WHERE I. YEAH-
HI THERE ARE. THE OTHER CONCERN
KELLER HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOW
WILL GO BACK TO AB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE AND WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL PROVIDE EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES EACH FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
SO. SURE BRIAN IF YOU'RE
PREPARED YOU CAN BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SHERRY FINGER DRAWN.
ACCERN COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SEVEN NINE WHICH
PROPOSES AT THE COUNTY SET DOWN
THE ARK MADERA MONO AND SAN
MATTEO IS THE LIST OF COUNTIES
KNOW THAT INFECTION EIGHT
THIRTY POINT ONE. THREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE. EIGHT
THIRTY POINT ONE CTC AUTHORIZES
PEACE OFFICER STATUS TWO
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
UNSPECIFIED COUNTIES WHILE ON
DUTY AND ENGAGED IN THE
PERFORMANCE OF THEIR DUTIES ALL
AND PERFORMING OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT DUTIES. DIRECTED BY
THEIR EMPLOYING AGENCY DURING A
LOCAL STATE OF EMERGENCY.
MARTIN CHANGE WOULD BE A FORCE
MULTIPLIER AND AN ADDED TOOL
FOR THE COUNTY'S OF MONO MADERA
DON'T KNOW OUR FAMILY CARE. IT
WOULD ALLOW CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS TO BE ARMED ABOUT
PERFORMING CORRECTIONS RELATED
TASKS SUCH AS TRANSPORT. IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE SHERIFF
COULD APPLY CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS DURING A LOCAL STATE
OF EMERGENCY INCREASE IN
AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO ASSIST
AFRICAN TO MANAGEMENT. EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN NINE HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAVE DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN CO AUTHOR. IS
CHANGING FAST IT WILL ALLOW
EACH COUNTY COULD BETTER SERVE
THEIR RESIDENT. AND I DON'T
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TOMORROW COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
MODEL COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. ALL SUPPORT EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. ALL OF MY
STUDY ESTá OF. RIGOROUS AND
THAT INTO. PRIOR TO BEING HIRED
FOR THEIR CONDITION. THEY ARE
HELD TO THE SAME BACKGROUND
STANDARDS AS A DEPUTY SHERIFF.
AUGUST THIRTIETH STAFF UNDERGO
EIGHT THIRTY TWO PC TRAINING
FOR ARREST AND CONTROL AND
FIRE. THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
REGULARLY QUALIFY WITH THEIR
FIREARMS. AND TO WHICH THEY ARE
HELD EXCEED THOSE REQUIRED FOR
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE TO. MISCARRIES MISTER
PERRY ON THE LINE FOR TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE. HE'S NOT ONLINE
OKAY THEN LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES INSIDE OF FORTY TWO
OH THREE. I SEE NINE HERE LET'S
GO TO OUR OVER FORMER ROOM A
TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NONE DIRE
HAS WHILE. MODERATOR CAN WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WATCHING TO SEE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. YES MR CARE
ACT TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI SEVEN SEVEN NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME YOU WANT TO GET. WHAT
DO I DO INTERNET SALES SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS AB ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN NINE AND CO HOST PLEASE
USE YOUR MUTE BUTTON WHEN NOT
SPEAKING THANK YOU. OUR FIRST
WITNESS TODAY WILL BE LYING
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY DOT SEVEN SEVEN
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AUDREY RETIRED
CHECK ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. AND AS A REMINDER
TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND AS A FINAL
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHER-
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO
YOUR MYSTERIES- READY TO
TESTIFY WILL GO BACK TO. ITS
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OR
ANY PAYER. SURE MEMBERS RAINY
PERRY HOME APPLE PORAC TOWN
MORE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. Q. BERMAN HE
IS ALWAYS GREAT I WILL GO BACK
ONE MORE TIME TO THE MODERATOR
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
IN ORDER TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A BI SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR STILL NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP GREAT NOW WILL MOVE
TO WITH THIS IS IN OPPOSITION I
SEE WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
LISTED IN OPPOSITION ACROSS YOU
HERNANDEZ. MODERATORS OKAY I'M
BEING TOWED MISTER HERNANDEZ IS
NOT AVAILABLE ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO THE ROOM KEY
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. I SEE NO WITNESSES AND
SO- IN OPPOSITION. AND I AM
LOOKING NOW AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR THIS PER AB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TWO SOLD. OPPOSITION. AND
NOBODY IS KILLING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT. BERICHTEN I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
RELATES TO AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
CENTER SKINNER. YES I HAVE A
QUESTION. SKINNER HAS A
QUESTION FOR ASSUME BIGELOW YOU
ACCEPT QUESTION. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IF WE
CLASSIFY THESE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE WAY THAT YOU'RE ASKING.
THAT THEY WOULD BE THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO CARRY WEAPONS IN
FACT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. HOWEVER
THEY WERE NEVER HAD THE SAME
LEVEL OF POST TRAINING
REGARDING WEAPONS IS THAT
CORRECT THAT THAT IS NOT A
CORRECT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THEY WILL HAVE THE SAME AS POST
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATIONS
ACCORDING TO SHERIFF BRAUN WHO
JUST TESTIFIED A MOMENTS AGO
SHE'S LIKE SHE SPELL THAT OUT.
AND I HI TO I HAVE
COTRADICTORY INFORMATION I
DON'T WANT TO INDICATE THAT THE
SHERIFF IS WRONG HOWEVER I'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT STATUTE IN
WOULD APPEAR THAT IT'S NOT THE
SAME LEVEL OF TRAINING IS NOT
REQUIRED. FOR CERTIFICATION. ON
THAT CARD THAT GIVES ME SOME
PAUSE. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. OKAY ARE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
FROM MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER WINNER. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN YEAH AND I JUST
MENTION THIS AYE AYE AYE AYE
THE SAME QUESTION A CENTER
SKINNER HAD EARLIER THIS BILL
HAS PASSED BEFORE IT'S BEEN
VETOED BEFORE THAT'S ALL OTHER
IF YOU SEEN GOVERNOR- AND THIS
IS LIKE SEEMS LIKE A SUPER
MESSY AREA OF THE LAW OR LIKE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES ARE
AUTHORIZED TO DO DIFFERENT
THINGS- AS I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND YOU KNOW- SERVICE SIMILAR
UNDERSTANDING TO WHAT'S AND
SKINNER EXPRESSED. THAT VIS.
THIS CATEGORY THE PENAL CODE.
OF OFFICERS. DON'T SOME OF THEM
HAVE FULL PRO CERTIFICATES BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO HAVE. FULL
CLOSER TO VEGAS THEY HAVE TO
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF FIREARM
TRAINING BUT IT MAY NOT. HAVE
TO BE THE FULL. ALONE POST- AND
SO AS A RESULT THERE ONLY
AUTHORIZED TO DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES AND CARRY A FIREARM IN
THE CUSTODIAL SETTING. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COUNTIES
WANT TO HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY
HAVEN'T TRANSPORT. PEOPLE AND
MUST BE ABLE TO BE FULL
OFFICERS DURING A TRANSPORT BUT
THE WAY THAT THE BILL INSIDE
CHRIS IN THE BILL IT'S JUST
THIS AREA OF THE LAW THE WAY
IT'S- STRUCTURED IT WOULD GIVE
THEM. THE ABILITY I COUNTY
COULD SEND THEM OFF ON THE
PATROL. BUT BUT I DON'T MAY
HAVE DONE THAT BUT THEY COULD
AND THEN THEY'LL BE OUT OF
CONTROL CARRYING A GUN. DOING
EVERYTHING THAT A POLICE
OFFICER DOES NOT NECESSARILY
HAVING THE FULL. LEVEL OF
TRAINING THAT OFFICER. WOULD
HAVE NOTS WILL RESIST THE-
CONCERN SO A ROOKIE WANT TO
RESPOND. TO THAT.THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THAT ARE
APPRECIATED IN YOUR YOUR
HISTORY IS CORRECT THIS BILL
HAS BEEN UP BEFORE FACTS BEEN
UP TWICE IN EACH. EACH TIME
IT'S COME UP BEFORE IT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDARS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BUILDING AND GOTTEN OUT AND
GONE TO THE GOVERNOR ONE TIME
IT WAS. THERE WAS TOO MANY
COUNTIES- WE HAD ACTUALLY
INCLUDED UP A LARGER NUMBER OF
COUNTIES THAT WANTED TO HAVE
THIS FLEXIBILITY AN- OPTION
AVAILABLE THAT SO MANY OTHER
COUNTIES ALREADY HAVE AND SO-
AT THE TIME IT WAS VETOED AS
YOU SAID- THIS LAST YEAR. BY
THE GOVERNOR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
MESSAGE WAS CLEAR HE- HE SAID
PLEASE BRING IT BACK IT'S JUST
WASN'T THE TIMING WASN'T RIGHT
FOR HIM AT THE MOMENT AND SO
HENCE HERE WE ARE THIS YEAR
ONCE AGAIN WITH A BILL THAT'S-
AGAIN. TYPICALLY BEEN ON
CONSENT CALENDAR AND ALL THE
WAY THROUGH NOW WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR QUESTIONS. AND CONCERNS.
OVER THE POST TRAINING I AGREE
WITH YOU WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
TRAINED IN THE- THE PEOPLE TO
HAVE ALL THE TRAINING. THAT'S
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND- PRUDENT WAY
AND RESPONSIBLE WAY. AND IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DO JUST LIKE OUR- DEPUTY
SHERIFFS THEY GO ON RESERVES
AND SUCH THEY ALL HAVE TO HAVE
THE POST CERTIFICATIONS. THEY
HAVE TO HAVE THE TRAININGS.
REQUIRED BY THE LOCAL SHERIFF'S
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO. SERVING
IN THESE CAPACITIES AS A SWORN
OFFICER SO. TO MIKE'S DEATH
KNOWLEDGE OF EXTENT I BELIEVE
THAT- THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE. AND WILL HAVE THE
TRAINING. SOTHAT THAT WAS MY
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING IN
MOVING THIS FORWARD. I DON'T
KNOW SHERIFF BRAUN IS HONOR IF
SHE'S GOT ANY- ADDED COMMENTS
THAT SHE WANTS TO ADD ON BUT IF
SHE'S NOT STILL ON THE LINE
THAT'S FINE. I'LL LET MY WORDS
STAND AS THEY ARE. SO MY
READERS ARE STILL AVAILABLE FOR.
YES THIS IS CHEVRON AND I AM I
STILL ON THE LINE. WE CAN HEAR
YOU. GREAT SO YES I DID THAT
EVEN THAT IT'S ONLY FOR CERTAIN
COUNTIES AS OF OCT IN PROCESS
THIS DOESN'T WORK FOR EVERY
COUNTY SO IT'S UP TO THE COUNTY
DECIDED. LEVEL- AT A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER MAKING THE
CORRECTIONAL DEPUTIES DOES THIS
WORK FOR OUR COUNTY TOOK AN OPT
FIT FOR EVERY COUNTY SO THE
COUNTY HAVE TO ASK TO BE PART
OF. YOU KNOW CODE WHICH IS WHY.
WE ARE GOING TO THIS PROCESS
FOR THE THIRD TIME AND THAT WAS
MISUNDERSTOOD IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE FIRST GO AROUND
WHEN I GOT TO KEEP IT WAS NOT
COMMUNICATED. WITH YOU REALIZE
THAT IT NEEDED TO BE
COMMUNICATED THAT WITH AN
ONGOING PROCESS AND- TO THE
POINT- WILL THEY BE PROPERLY
TRAINED ALL OF MY DEPUTIES. AND
MY CORRECTION OFFICERS THEY
TRAIN TOGETHER THEY'LL GO
THROUGH THE SAME TRAINING.
EVERY CORRECTIONAL. OFFICER
THAT I HAVE AND THAT THE OTHER
COUNTIES HAVE GO THROUGH. THE
TRAINING THAT'S REQUIRED EIGHT
THIRTY TWO PC. AND THEY WILL I
WOULDN'T. PUT THEM OUT ON THE
STREET- AS DEPUTIES DURING
TRAFFIC STOP. THAT NATURE
BECAUSE IF GIVES THEM- AN ADDED
LAYER OF PROTECTION WHILE THEY
ARE. WORKING IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION OKAY I HAVE A FIRE
LIKE WE HAD. A FIRE AND I HAVE
VERY LIMITED RESOURCES I HAVE
INCLUDING ME. TWENTY FOUR FOUR
DEPUTIES. FOUR THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES I AM VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES TO THIS IS OF
COURSE MULTIPLIER FOR ME TO
HAVE THAT ADDED RESOURCE WHERE
I CAN. GET MY CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS. ANOTHER BASIS YOU
HAVE TO GO OUT AND HELP IN AN
EMERGENCY OR HAVE THEM ARMS FOR
TRANSPORT FOR THE DAY OUR STATE
SO THAT THE COMMUNITY IS. AND A
DANGEROUS AND MAKE. THIS IS A
REASONABLE NEED TO ADDRESS-
CONCEALED KERRY PARK OF IT BACK
IS. TRUE THAT IS THAT THEY
WOULD. HAVE FULL PEACE OFFICER
STATUS. AND BE ALLOWED TO CARRY
CONCEALED AT EVERY PEACE
OFFICER IS ALLOWED TO CARRY
CONCEALED. AS I STATED IN MY
EARLIER TESTIMONY ALL OF MY-
CORRECTIONAL STAFF WHO WISH TO
HAVE THAT A CONCEALED CARRY
PERMIT ALREADY DEAL IN TRADE
PARTNER BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND
EVERYTHING THAT IS NECESSARY TO
MAKE SURE THAT I AM NOT PUTTING
A GUN INTO THE HANDS OF A
PERSON WHO SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. THIRTY
NINE CENTER I MEAN SOMEONE
BIGELOW CHART CLOSE I WOULD
JUST HOPE THAT THE WORDS OF THE
SHARP- HELPED ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN EACH FIND IN
EUROPE. BY THINKING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I'D ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU- MEMBERS I'VE
HEARD YOUR CONCERNS ON AND
CLEAR AND I KNOW THERE'S SOME
HAZARDS C. ON. THIS ISSUE
TODAY- ITEM THAT WE'VE SEEN
BEFORE- WE DO HAVE A TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SO I AM.
SEEKING A MOTION HERE TODAY.
ERIC UNDERSTANDING IF WE FAIL
TO GET A MOTION WILL BE-
WILLING TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION- SOME BIGELOW-
THAT WOULD BE YOUR DESIRE WE
CAN HOLD THIS ITEM OFF UNTIL-
UPCOMING HEARING IN A TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
ORDER.
BIGELOW TO LISTEN ON A
READINESS FIVE. DON'S MISS
COMMITTEE AND SOME CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED TO DATE WE'RE
GONNA PULL THIS ITEM FROM
AGENDA AND WE'LL RESCHEDULE IT
FOR ANOTHER HEARING AND FOR YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RICHARD THE DAYS IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH YOU THAT'S VERY FAIR I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY EACH OF THE
MEMBERS AND HOPEFULLY- WITH
THIS EXTRA TIME ALLOW ME TO.
THE OPPORTUNITY AND- THE FOLKS
THAT ARE LISTED IN THIS ILL TO
BE ABLE TO- SPEAK TO EACH OF
YOU AND FIND A WAY TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE US
HERE TODAY ALSO HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A FULL BODY HERE- FOR THE
NEXT HEARING WHAT WE MAY HAVE
A- BETTER OPTION FOR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS
APPRECIATED. ALL RIGHT NOW
MOVING ON TO YOUR NEXT ITEM AB
TWELVE TEN. US I SEE ITS
IMPLEMENTING IS HERE AS HE
PREPARED FOR HIS TESTIMONY AS
SOON AS WE CLEAN UP THE PODIUM
WILL. ALLOW US TO MOVE MEMBER
TEAM TO MAKE HIS PRESENTATION
ON A V. TWELVE. THANK IN MATURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LET ME JUST
FIRST THANK YOU WHEN YOUR
STAFF- FOR PRESENTING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THEM WHICH IS A TO
SPECIFIC PERCENTAGE OF
COMMISSIONERS. WITH HER
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE RATHER
THAN A NUMBER SO THAT IS A
BOARD AS A BOARD SIZE ME
CHANGED A PORTION OF
REPRESENTATION WITHIN THE BOARD
IS MAINTAINED. AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE COMMISSIONERS WHO SERVE ON
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS MAKE VERY. CRITICAL
DECISIONS HI EVEN THOUGH
THAT PROFESSIONAL. THE DOESN'T
REQUIRE ANY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE EXISTING LAW DOES
MANDATE THAT THESE
COMMISSIONERS SHOULD REFLECT
THE CROSS SECTION OF RACIAL
SEXUAL ECONOMIC AND GEOGRAPHIC
FEATURES OF THE POPULATION. THE
CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY THE
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY
OVERWHELMINGLY COMES FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUNDS IN
DOESN'T REPRESENT THAT
DIVERSITY. AB TWELVE TEN
REQUIRE THAT AT LEAST 60% OF
COMMISSIONERS ON THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS HAVE SPECIFIED
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUNDS BUT
DROUGHT BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. FIVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PROFESSOR HAD DARK- I'VE I'VE
RUN FROM THE UC HASTINGS AS
WELL AS A TEAM IN A JOHNSON
FROM UNCOMMON LAW. ARE YOUR
SEARCH KEY WITNESSES PREPARED
RIGHT NOW IF THAT'S- I WOULD
HOPE SO LET'S SEE IF THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP TO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. TWELVE TEN. BOB
DOLE'S LIFE SHOULD BE. OPEN
BIGGEST NEED ON MUTE THEIR LINE
FOR ME PROFESSOR YOU PREPARED.
I'M HERE THANK YOU. THERE WE GO
OKAY WE'LL START WITH OUR
PROFESSOR OPERON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TEN MY
NAME IS DOROTHY RAHMAN A LAW
PROFESSOR AT UC HASTINGS I HAVE
A BOOK THAT RECENTLY CAME OUT
YESTERDAY MONSTERS WHICH IS THE
PRODUCT OF YEARS OF RESEARCH
AND IT'S AN IN DEPTH
EXAMINATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
PAROLE HEARING SYSTEM. I ALSO
COORDINATE THE NATIONAL
RESEARCH NETWORK ON PULL ONE OF
MY MAIN OBSERVATIONS OF THE
BOOK WAS THAT WHILE THE BOARD
IS DIVERSE IN TERMS OF RACE AND
GENDER IT IS NOT DIVERSE IN
TERMS OF PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
COMMISSIONERS COME FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUNDS FORMER
SHERIFFS POLICE CHIEFS AND
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. THIS FAR
REACHING IMPLICATIONS OF TO THE
NATURE AND RESULT OF THE
HEARINGS THE CURRENT
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD THE
FACT THAT SEVERAL
TRANSFORMATION TO CALIFORNIA
PUNISHMENT BUT HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT THE LATE NINETEEN
SEVENTY TO NINETY EIGHT OVER
THE YEARS THE TIME BEFORE THE
INITIAL HEARING AT BETWEEN
HEARINGS INCREASED ACTUARIAL
RISK ASSESSMENT REPLACED
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS. THE ROLE OF
PROSECUTORS AND VICTIM
SUPPORTERS EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASED AND VOTERS APPROVED A
GUBERNATORIAL VETO ON PAROLE
BOARD DECISION TO RELEASE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY FOUR
STATES THAT HAVE THIS
ADDITIONAL POLITICAL KEEP
GATEKEEPING FUNCTION ON IT COLD
SYSTEM DESPITE REPEATED
INSTRUCTIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURTS TO
FOCUS ON THE PRO APPLICANTS
FUTURE PROSPECTS AND RISKS THE
BOARD ACT DEFENSIVELY FINDING
WAYS TO BYPASS THIS REQUIREMENT
AND DENIED PAROLE ON THE BASIS
OF CRIME THAT HAPPENED DECADES
AGO. EVEN TO PEOPLE WHO
ACCORDING TO ROBUST
CRIMINOLOGICAL RESEARCH UP LONG
GO EACH DAY OUT OF CRIME THE
CONSEQUENCES RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE RELEASED A RARE ACCOUNTING
FOR ONLY 16217% OF ALL
HEARINGS. IT IS UNSURPRISING
THAT A GROUP COMPRISED ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IS PROFESSIONALLY AND
CULTURALLY PREDISPOSED TO
ACCEPT COURT RECORDS AND
DISCIPLINARY WRITE UPS OF
INCONTROVERTIBLE TRUTHS MAKE
BIASED ASSUMPTIONS. ABOUT
PEOPLE FROM THEIR DEMEANOR AND
BODY A LANGUAGE. AND THEY TEND
TO LOOK AND THERE OF EXPENSE OF
MORE CALL STORIES PEOPLE
ENVIRONMENT AND CIRCLE. THE
COMMISSIONERS ALSO EXHIBIT
REGARDING THE WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE USE OF OUR PRISON
PROGRAMMING SYSTEM LAYING THE
BLAME FOR INACCESSIBLE OR
NONEXISTENT REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS ON THE FOR ALL
APPLICANTS THEMSELVES DESPITE
SOME CONTINUING EDUCATION
WORKSHOPS THE COMMISSIONERS OF
THE GROUP DO NOT POSSESS DEEP
PROFESSIONAL KNOWLEDGE ON
ISSUES SUCH AS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH. THE
COMMISSIONER REGULARLY PRIDE
THEMSELVES FOR BEING ABLE TO
DETECT FALSE REMORSE OR LACK OF
INSIGHT UNFORTUNATELY THIS SELF
ASSESSMENT CLAIM IS
CONTRADICTED BY THE PAST
UMBILICAL RESEARCH EXPERIMENTS
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
REGULARLY EXPRESSED
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE CERTAINTY
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO DETECT
LIFE. AND REGULARLY DO
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION IN TELLING
TRUTH AND LIES THE PARKS. WE
ARE IN A UNIQUE MOMENT IN
HISTORY IN WHICH WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT MULTIPLE FORMS OF WISDOM
AND EXPERTISE NOT ONLY THE
EXPERTISE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE ESSENTIAL TO SOLVE
SOCIAL PROBLEMS AND OFFER HOPE
TO FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB ONE TWO
ONE ZERO SO THAT PAROLE BOARDS
ARE ANOTHER SITE OPEN
TRANSFORMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS- DAMIEN
JOHNSON. MODERATORS MISTER
JOHNSONVILLE. YES I AM PLEASE
GO AHEAD BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
MEANT. MY NAME IS DAMIEN
JOHNSON I'M A LEGAL ASSISTANT
ADAM COMMON LAW I'M- CITIZENS
WITH WEEKLY BEEN DISCHARGED
FROM PAROLE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
A B. TWELVE CHAIR. WHY DO BIRDS
CLUB BOARD. AS SOMEONE WHO
ATTENDED ELEVEN CORALS ABILITY
HEARINGS DURING MY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS MCCARTY RATIONS. I COULD
SHARE MY EXPERIENCES. BEFORE
PRO BOWL THAT IS ALL
EXCLUSIVELY MADE UP OF LOS. OR
COMMIT LOG BACK. MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION COMMISSIONER SEEM TO
HAVE A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
THE ENVIRONMENT I GREW UP. AND
ITS AFFECT ON THE DECISION BY
MAY A COMMON REPLY WAS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS COULD
HAPPEN OR HOW IT COULD AFFECT
YOU IN THIS WAY HE OR THAT
MAKES NO SENSE. EVERYONE KNEW
THAT I WAS READY TO COME HOME
INCLUDING CORRECTIONAL STAFF.
HOWEVER THE COMMISSIONERS TO BE
TO SPEAK A CERTAIN WAY BECAUSE
THEY WOULD. THE RELEASE ME I
FOUND THE COMMISSIONER FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO HAVE
NEVER BEEN A PART OF THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM FILLED
UNDERSTAND. WE'LL KEEP
ACCESSING POSITIVE PRISON
PROGRAM. I WAS REPEATEDLY
CENTER COULD NOT BE DISPLAYED
IN PROGRAMS THAT DID NOT EXIST
IN THE PRESENT I WAS COMPILING
TWO FORMER NOT AVAILABLE TO ME
BECAUSE- COOKED TO THE LEVEL.
APPOINTING A MORE DIVERSE BOARD
WOULD HAVE FAR REACHING
IMPLICATIONS THAT GO WAY BEYOND
MY CASE. FOR CAR THREE WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN ABUSED BY THEIR
PARTNERS AND HAVE EXPERIENCED
COMIC OR ELDERLY PAROLE
APPLICANTS. WITH DEALING WITH
MEDICAL ISSUES THAT THAT
CURRENT MEASURES ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT WITH SO MANY OTHERS BEHIND
BARS FOR THE BOARDS BOARD.
WOULD BE BETTER ABLE TO SEE THE
WHOLE PERSON NOT JUST THEIR
ACTIONS. IT WOULD HELP IT WOULD
ALSO HELP THE BOARD HAD MORE
REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS ABOUT
INCREASING PROGRAM WHICH IS
CRUCIAL TO DETERMINING PAROLE
SUITABILITY. INCLUDING THAT
THANK. YOU ALL. THE TIME AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB
TWELVE TEN BECAUSE DIVERSIFIED
THE BOARD INCLUDING HAVING A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
COMMISSIONER. WOULD MAKE IT
MORE RECEPTIVE TO UNDERSTAND
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS CULTURES.
LIKE EXPERIENCES THAT EXPRESSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU THINK
THREE ROAD NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE AYE SHE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND NOW WILL
LOOK TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND I
SEE KNOW WHAT THIS IS-
MODERATOR ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN Q. WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CARE AGAIN NOT TO
SHOW SUPPORTFOR A BI TWELVE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH LINE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY
TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS THIS IS
DIANA CORRECT ARM OUT ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANVILLE'S AUTO ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. IN LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES MY NAME
TO BE JOKERS OTHER POLICY
DIRECTOR ON COMMON LAW. WE'RE
SUPPORT NUMBER EIGHTEEN A FEW
ORGANIZATIONS- SUPPORT TO. MARK
CALIFORNIA INSIDE GARDEN
PROGRAM ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
PRISON POLICY INITIATIVE WILL
REBOUND RESTORED JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS AND ISSUE JUST THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LATER TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN GETTING
NOBODY ELSE QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO PRIMARY WITNESS LISTED IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION NOR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR WOULD NOW
MOVES TO THE PHONE LINES ARE DO
WE HAVE CALLERS IN Q. WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE TEN. EXPRESS OPPOSITION
FOR AB TWELVE TEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB. TWELVE
TEN. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. THANK YOU I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO THE
SENATOR WINNER. MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU- SOME
ROUTINE YOUR BILL BRINGING THIS
BEFORE US BECAUSE I DO THINK
THAT ARE. SOME CHANGES IN THE
COMPOSITION OF OUR PAROLE BOARD
ARE WE- WHILE THE CRITERIA FOR.
THE CREATURES THAT YOU'RE
ADDING CARTERI FOR THEIR YOU
KNOW THAT THE MEAT COUGH. IS
GOOD. IS THERE ROOM NOW. FOR
OBVIOUSLY THESE DIFFERENT
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUNDS ARE
GOOD- BUT I'M JUST THINKING
ABOUT- WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE INCARCERATED.
IT IS RARE FOR THEM TO HAVE
SUCH PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUNDS
AND WHILE THERE IS PROVISION IN
YOUR BILL FOR ONE PERSON TO
HAVE BEEN- FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. I'M JUST THINKING
ABOUT THE BUDGET THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IN FACT I'M I'M SORT OF
NOT THAT THE PAROLE COMMISSION
NEEDS TO BE COMPARABLE TO A
JURY BUT I'M THINKING ABOUT IT
HOW. ARE PRINCIPLES OF A JURY
ARE THAT YOU ARE. YOU ARE
JUDGED BY YOUR PEERS. AND THAT.
IT THERE SEEMS TO ME TO BE OF
VALUE. TO PEOPLE WHO CAN JUST
RELATE TO A PERSON'S
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND SO WHAT I'M
WONDERING. AND MAYBE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ENOUGH ABOUT THE
CURRENT CRITERIA FOR BREAK IS
THIS ONLY COVERS THIS WILL
COVER YOUR NEW CRITERIA WILL
COVER SIXTY PERCENT. IS A
CURRENT CRITERIA SUCH THAT
EIGHT. A PERSON WITH GENERIC
KNOWLEDGE WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
APPOINTED. UP UP WITH PROBABLY
NOPE. STANDARDS BACK REQUIRED
OF FULL. WHAT IS IN. IT DID
THIS IS WHAT THE STATURE BUT IS
ALSO WHAT HAPPENS REALITY. THE
STATUES THE COMMISSION SHOULD
REFER THE CAR SECTION OF RACIAL.
SEXUAL AT IN YOU FEATURE OF THE
POP. OF CAL TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
FIELD THAT INCLUDES SOCIOLOGY
AND MENTAL HEALTH I GET IT.
ANYBODY COULD ABSOLUTELY BUT
THEY DON'T TENANTS HAS. CORRECT
ONE BACK OKAY CORRECT GOT THE
GOVERNOR THE BILL TO. A TO
PAROLE BOARD'S. BOB HAS NOT.
OKAY THE MORE PAST GOVERNORS
HAVE PRESS COVERS HAVE NOT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU A QUESTION
SOONER KERR- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- VISITING I HAD A
QUESTION THIS BILL. A FALL
UNDER THE LARGEST THAT'S PASSED.
THAT HAS BEEN PASSED IN THE
PAST. THAT RECALL ON JAN
DIVERSE ON BOARDS INCOME. I
DON'T IF IT WAS SENATOR HERE AT
THE TIME. OR I KNOW HOLDEN DID
ONE LAST YEAR FOR PRIVATE BILLS
FOR BOARDS ARE BUT DID WE DID
WE HAVE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN
THE PAST THAT I WOULD. I
CARRIED WILL FIRST NORM TURNER
IF IT GOT. MAY I DON'T KNOW BUT
I GET BACK YOU WITH DEFINITELY.
THAT IS A GOOD. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT A IS ANY. IN BE
THAT THE COMP. TO THE LARGEST
THAT'S PASSED IN THE- ABOUT-
DIVERSIFY BOARDS AND COME. IT
WAS MY- LOOK BACK ON IT I MEAN
AS A PROFESSOR SAID- THE RACIAL
AND DIVERSE HAS BEEN. AN ISSUE-
BUT REALLY HAVE TO ISSUE HAS
BEEN THE- LAW OF PROFESSIONAL.
DIVERSITY PROGRAM BURKE BUT ARE
HAPPY MAKE SURE THAT WERE
COMPLAIN WITH- ALL IN ELSE HAS
BEEN. OKAY IN THIS ROOM
THINKING I GOING TO THANK YOU
FOR THOSE- SOCIETY I THINK THE
BETTER THAT PAROLE BOARD IS IN
DIVERSITY AND MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BETTER OFF WALL
B. AND M. BETTER SERVE THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME SO ON THAT NOTE- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER
WE HAVE A TO PASS- SO
CONSULTANT PLEASE COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB ONE AB
TWELVE GEN AB TWELVE TEN THE
PAST BRADFORD. AYE IT SHOWED
BOTH COM LONGER COME LATER AYE
SKINNER BY. IN OUR AYE WIENER.
WHEN OUR EYES FOR THE THAT
MEASURE HAS FOR VOTE TO OUT
GRADUALLY IT'S ROUTE. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ALLOW US ITEM BY
SENATOR CALL MARGARET AB TWELVE.
ONE TWO SEVEN. WHEREVER YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE. WHILE WAITING I
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALLOW ARE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR COUNSEL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LONG
CONCERNED KELLER CONSENT
CALENDAR WINNER. AYE WIENER AYE
FOR VOTES THE MEASURES OUT FOUR
ZERO. SENATOR WHEN YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY BEGIN. A CHAIR AND GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING. AB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. WHICH AMENDS THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE TO PERMIT
AN EMPLOYEE OF A PUBLIC
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE TO PRESENT
A PROBABLE CAUSE DETERMINATION
TO A JUDGE. IN SEEKING AN
ARREST WARRANT IN CASES WHERE
THE SUBJECT IS A PEACE OFFICER.
THE AIM IS TO REDUCE PROCEDURAL
BARRIERS TWO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. BY ELIMINATING
ONE OF THEMFOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND INITIATING
PROSECUTIONS AGAINST MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO. CURRENTLY
AN ARREST WARRANT REQUIRES A
JUDGE TO FIND PROBABLE CAUSE
FOR ARREST. AND OUR PENAL CODE
RIGHT NOW REQUIRES THAT A PEACE
OFFICER MUST ESTABLISH PROBABLE
CAUSE TO SUPPORT THE ARREST
WARRANT OF ONE OF THEIR OWN.
WHICH MEANS THAT CURRENTLY WHEN
PROSECUTORS ARE SEEKING AN
ARREST WARRANT FOR A MEMBER OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY NEED THE
COOPERATION OF ANOTHER PEACE
OFFICER. IN ORDER TO SUPPLY
THAT JUDGE WITH THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION NEEDED TO ESTABLISH
PROBABLE CAUSE AND AS WE KNOW.
NO ONE LIKES A SNITCH WHICH
MAKES THIS REALLY HARD TO DO.
SO AB ONE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
CLARIFY THAT A DECLARATION OF
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR AN ARREST
WARRANT NEED NOT BE PROVIDED
ONLY BY A PEACE OFFICER BUT%
COULD ALSO BE PROVIDED BY A
PROSECUTOR. THE PROPOSED CHANGE
IN LAW WOULD MAKE NO OTHER
CHANGES TO THE PROCESS OF
OBTAINING AN ARREST WARRANT
BEYOND THE EXPANSION OF
POSSIBLE AFGHANS BEYOND PEACE
OFFICERS AND IT WOULD NOT
CHANGE THE PROBABLE CAUSE
STANDARD OF PROOF. AND JUDGES
WOULD STILL RETAIN THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE AN ARREST
WARRANT. WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
CHESS OF UDINE THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY. WE
WILL ALLOW YOU TO SET A COUPLE
OF- FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY THANK YOU CHAIR BRADFORD
YEAH COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I AM THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CHANGEABLE- AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK. HELPING CALIFORNIA
TO MOVE TOWARDS SAFER STRONGER
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO FOR THEATTENTION TO CRITICAL ISSUES
INVOLVING POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY.
ON THAT WANT TO THANK THANK
CENTER COME LONGER. FOR HER
WORK ON THIS ISSUE- IT MOVING
TOWARDS AN IMPORTANT CHANGE. IN
THE LAW. IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
NATION GREENBANK OR DANTE RIGHT
FOR GEORGE FLOYD FOR BRIANNA
TAYLOR AND SHARKS ARE TOO MANY
OTHERS KILLED AT THE HANDS OF
POLICE. PUBLIC OUTRAGE HAS LED
TO A DEMAND FOR GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN THE IN
RESPONSE TO POLICE VIOLENCE.
EVEN WITH THIS INCREASE CALL
ACCOUNT IT REMAINS RARE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO INITIATE
PROSECUTIONS AGAINST POLICE
OFFICERS WHO VIOLATE. THE LAW
WHILE ON DUTY LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT IT TOOK A NATIONAL PROTEST
MOVEMENTS BEFORE CHARGES WERE
FINALLY FILED AGAINST THE
OFFICERS WHO KILL GEORGE FLOYD.
THE ONE OBSTACLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PROSECUTION OF
POLICE OFFICERS IS THE
UNWILLINGNESS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ASSIST IN THE
PROSECUTION OF ONE OF THEIR OWN.
IT CAN LEAD TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS REFUSING TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION TO
SUPPORT OR INVESTIGATE AND
ARREST WARRANT. AB ONE TWO
SEVEN IS A PRACTICAL AND
NECESSARY SIMPLE CHANGE IN THE
LAW THAT WOULD ADDRESS ONE OF
THESE BARRIERS TO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY SH THE PROPOSED
CHANGE IN LAW DOES NOT IN ANY
WAY MODIFY THE ROLE OF THE
MAGISTRATE OR JUDGE IN MAKING
THE FINAL DETERMINATION ABOUT
WHETHER. ENOUGH EVIDENCE EXISTS
TO INITIATE THE CASE. WE
EXPANDS COOL CAT CASTLES TO THE
INFORMATION IN THE
INVESTIGATION BEFORE A JUDGE.
WELL BECAUSE EXISTS FOR REST
WHEN THE SUBJECT OF THAT ARREST
IS A PEACE OFFICER THIS IS A
NARROW AND SIMPLE AND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO ELIMINATE A
BARRIER TO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY IT WOULD ALLOW
FOR MORE THAN ONLY A PEACE
OFFICER TO ATTACHED TO THE
EVIDENCE IN AN INVESTIGATION-
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
THOSE CASES. WHERE A PEACE
OFFICER IS THE SUBJECT OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. UNDER THIS LAW
AS STATED BY SENATOR COM LOG
AND IMPLODE THE OF A PUBLIC
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE EVEN IF NOT
A SWORN PEACE OFFICER WOULD
ALSO BE ALLOWED TO MAKE A
DECLARATION IN SUPPORT OF
PROBABLE CAUSE. TO A JUDGE OR
MAGISTRATE. IS PRESIDENT FROM
OTHER STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY
FOR THIS PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW
THERE ARE IN FACT NINE STATES.
THAT ALLOW PERSONS OTHER THAN A
PEACE OFFICER TO ATTEST THAT
PROBABLE CAUSE EXISTS COURT
ARREST WARRANT SHE WAS NINE
STATES INCLUDING. NEW JERSEY
NORTH CAROLINA SOUTH CAROLINA
PENNSYLVANIA MARYLAND OHIO
TEXAS VIRGINIA AND GEORGIA SH.
AND THIS CHANGE WILL ALSO CRACK
THE LAW AS IT EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH REGARD TO
SEARCH WARRANT AFFIDAVIT SHE IN
SHORT. CHANGES PRACTICAL IT'S
NECESSARY AND IT'S COMMON
PRACTICE IN MANY OTHER STATES.
FOR THESE REASONS I AM PROUD TO
SPONSOR. AB ONE TWO SEVEN FIVE
OR DRIVE VOTE TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE AND SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO
SEVEN. SENIOR HEARING NINE WILL
MOVE NOW TO TWENTY FORTY THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES THEIR-
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP WITH
DECISION SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE WHO WERE IN
SUPPORT OF. AB. ONE TWO SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE TWO SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS
GOING TO GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE THEN PLACE YOU BACK
INTO THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND OUR FIRST PARTICIPANT
WILL BE LINE THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LAST SEMESTER FOR
PROSECUTORS LINE FOR CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THIS.
WE WILL ALIGN TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CANACCORD ARNELLE ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BY EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. HI THIS IS ROBIN BURKE ON
THE APP OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR
THE CO SPONSOR AND WITH
PERMISSION I'M GOING TO ANALYST
ADDITIONAL QUARTER. THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OF THE
COUPONS ARE CALIFORNIA. STATE
THE AND CHAPTER. OAKLAND POLICE
COMMISSION PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCES CALIFORNIA. AND
UNAPOLOGETICALLY HURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL APPLY FOR IT.
THANK YOU SORRY MR CAROLINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL THE CARE OF ON THE TOP
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. Q.
THE QUICKNESS. FINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. TO
ME TO SEE WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER TO
SHOW SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FINAL
EVENT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TEMPLE
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND AS A
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. HARPER AB.
ONE TWO SEVEN. MISTER CARE
THERE'S NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU HOW BRING BACKTO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO AB ONE TWO SO. ALL
MOVE IT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS CENTER
COMMON RETORT CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY WE HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
MEASURE- COUNCIL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB ONE TWO SEVEN.
AB ONE TWO SEVEN BRADFORD TIME
TO PROVIDE CHOI BOGUE COM LAGER
HI I'M LIKE- I SKINNER. ENTER
WINNER. WIENER FIVE FOUR ZERO
THAT MEASURE FOUR VOTES YOUR
OUT CONGRADULATIONS SENATOR
FROM LONGER. AND. HE. MEMBERS
THAT INCLUDES ALL THE ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE ON JUNE ON THE
GENDER TODAY THANK YOU ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIF
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PATIENTS AND YOUR COOPERATION
SO- THIS WILL CONCLUDE. OUR
AGENDA FOR THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND WE STAND
ADJOURNED.